Salut, la semaine dernière,
j'étais à Aix-en-Provence.
Et en fait, grâce au principe de retour temporel.
Je suis de retour à Aix en Provence.
Et j'ai quelqu'un avec moi, c'est Blandine.
Tu ne sais pas qui est Blandine.
Est-ce que tu sais qui tu es ?
Non.
Hahaha, c'est magique.
Non, c'est parce que tu m'as pris par la main dans la rue.
Tu m'as dit de venir, ça fait vachement peur.
Blandine, c'est la première abonnée.
C'est la première d'entre vous à être venue me voir.
Blandine, c'est quoi ton nom
dans les commentaires à chaque fois ?
- Dine (blabla) - Dine (blabla) ... ?
- "Dine" tout court        - Dine tout court ça ira.
Et donc elle est venue à ma première représentation,
ici, à Aix.
C'était mercredi soir avec Quentin, son chéri.
Et c'est la première fois que je rencontre une abonnée.
Blandine, je suis ravi !
- Moi aussi.
Blandine, on se fait un petit numéro ensemble ?
- Oui.
Ok, on va se faire un truc, j'ai réfléchi à ça.
Est-ce que tu as des animaux ?
- Non.
Est-ce que tu avais des animaux étant petite ?
- Non plus.
Non ? Alors t'as jamais eu d'animaux ?
Mais ton chéri a eu des animaux, c'est ça ?
- Tout à fait.
Ok, il a un chien ? Un chat ?
Un poisson ? Ce genre de choses ?
- Tout ça.
Ok, ah oui tout ça ? Même le poisson ?
- Non..
Non, le chat a mangé le poisson !
* rires *
Je ne savais pas jusqu'à maintenant qu'il avait des animaux,
tu confirmes que je ne pouvais pas savoir tout ça ?
- J'confirme.
On va jouer alors avec le chat de ton chéri
de la manière suivante.
Tu prends la feuille.
Tu en fais une boulette.
Et tu la mets dans ta main.
Donc tu tiens bien la boulette comme ça,
qu'on la voit aussi à la caméra
* rires *
*imitation*   C'est pas assez froissé...
Et donc ça, on imagine que c'est une boulette avec laquelle pourrait jouer un chat.
Tu vois, virtuellement ok ?
Je vais me retourner, on va le voir à la caméra
et toi, ce que tu vas faire
c'est que tu vas cacher la boulette,
soit dans ta main gauche,
Soit dans ta main droite, soit dans ta poche.
Tu vas pouvoir faire ce que tu veux.
Main gauche, main droite ou dans ta poche, d'accord ?
Quand c'est fait, tu mets les deux mains
comme ça les poings vers le bas.
Et tu me dis que c'est bon.
- Ok.
C'est bon ?
- Oui
Ok !
Alors je te pose deux questions
et il y aura un petit truc en plus.
Ce qui est amusant c'est qu'à partir de maintenant,
Tu vas décider de toujours me mentir,
ou de toujours me dire la vérité.
C'est toi qui décides.
Donc prends-toi un temps de réflexion, dans ta tête,
tu te dis "ok, je ne dirai que la vérité ou je dirai que des mensonges"
Ou tu mens, ou tu dis la vérité, ça j'en sais rien !
Et c'est ça la difficulté du truc
T'as pris ta décision dans ta tête ?
- Oui
Première question : est-ce que la boulette est dans tes mains ?
- Non
Non... Okay.
Arrrgghh..... Elle a la pression !
Euh...moi aussi !
Deuxième question :
Est-ce que la boulette est dans ta main gauche ?
- Non
Okay... c'était assez intéressant.
Je t'avais dit deux questions et un truc en plus.
Le truc en plus va être le suivant,
je vais me retourner de nouveau
Si la boulette est dans ta main droite disons, tu la mets dans ta poche.
Si elle est dans ta poche,
tu la mets dans ta main gauche
Si elle est dans ta main gauche, t'as pas de mouvement à faire.
Du coup, fais semblant de faire
quelque chose quand même pour m'induire en erreur.
Tu me dis quand c'est bon.
- Ok.
Ok, c'est bon ?
Si j'ai bien pris en compte toutes tes réactions.
Si j'ai pris en compte le temps
et les mouvements que tu as fait,
Je dirais que la boulette est dans ta main gauche.
Est-ce que j'ai bon?
- Et oui.
Oui, ok, la boulette est là !
C'est la boulette de ton chat, du chat de ton copain.
Alors, cette boulette, elle symbolisai le jeu qu'on peut avoir avec le chat de ton copain.
Est-ce que tu pourrais imaginer maintenant, en tendant la main comme ça,
que c'est le chat de ton chéri, le chat de Quentin.
- HmmHmm
Faut imaginer en fait qu'il a la forme du chat
et qu'il y avait son nom de tatoué dessus
- Hmmhmm
Et je pense que ce chat là a un nom particulier.
- Oui
C'est vrai ?
Je pense que ce chat-là a un nom
à consonance un peu pays du sud
ou comme les consonances un peu polonaises,
ce genre de choses.
- Je ne sais pas.
Tu ne sais pas d'où ça vient ?
- Ben, plus à l'est
Je dirais, je dirais que.....
Ca finit en....
Peut-être en consonnance en i
- Hmmhmm
Tu vois, des choses un peu sèches
C'est vrai ?
- Oui
Et je dirais que le chat de Quentin s'appelle...
J'hésite avec un trois syllabes mais je dirais ...
Touski ou quelque chose comme ça
* rire nerveux *
C'est ça ??
- C 'est pas loin
C'est pas loin, c'était quoi ?
- Tsuki
Tsuki ! et j'ai dit ? Tuski !?!
Oh, on est pas mal, moi je dis que j'ai bon,
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire, je dis que j'ai bon.
Merci beaucoup Blandine.
- Je ne comprends pas
Tsuki ? C'est très joli mais je ne sais pas du tout
d'où ça vient ça.
- Par là....
On est pas sur que ce soit l'Est là...
Ah oui, d'ailleurs on est en train de voir
tout le fond du spectacle d'hier soir
Ca t'a plu ?
- Oui
C'est vrai ?
- Ouais ! Franchement..
Cool,
merci Blandine, tu es la première abonnée
Je suis vraiment, vraiment ravi que tu sois venue
Tu as vu comment j'étais content
qu'on se rencontre l'autre soir
- C'est vrai
- Abonnez-vous à la chaîne !
Et c'est Blandine qui le dit, il faut l'écouter elle !
Abonne-toi à la chaîne, met un petit pouce en l'air
Commente, fais tout ce que tu veux
Et rendez-vous demain à 17h
pour le prochain MentalVlog
Tchao !